[Music]
you've spoken
and i've julie responded it seems that
seeing anime characters flex their
superiority and just stomping over
hapless opponents is your thing so i've
come with a second volume of such list
now prepare to be amazed and dazzled by
10 more showings of power from some of
the most popular anime characters off
the top of my head remember it's these
moments that oftentimes just establish
and make characters and in my opinion
they did a damn good job in doing so
a lot of these characters became much
more memorable through these segments
and thanks to the same moments we also
got some really interesting power level
debates
before we get going i've noticed that a
sizeable part of you aren't subscribed
to the channel so with that i'd like to
encourage you to hit that subscribe
button if you're a regular watcher of my
videos that way you can be notified the
next time i post something without
further ado
let's get going to the list
ironically our list begins with the
battle at the beginning in this case
it's afro samurai skirmish against
bandits there are only
so few things that you can say about a
massacre of that scale happening right
in front of your eyes
gotta give props to the production team
for this one but if we're looking at it
as just a fight the bandits are no more
than a minor speed bump for afro
samurai's quest
a big show of power at that i like the
positioning of this battle because it
quickly establishes afro samurai as one
badass who's super powerful
it also gives the viewers an
introduction to the artistic style of
afro samurai it easily sets the tone of
what to expect moving forward
before we continue with your favorite
showcases of power moments in anime how
about finding a way to do so in the
virtual world with arkansas games epic
rpg and the sponsors of this video
dragon raja dragon raja takes you into a
lush and vivid world where you get to
start your adventure as one of the many
classes available
the newest one the phantom sound really
catches my attention i've been a fan of
the bard classes in video games and
being able to play as a unique take on
that is really a dream come true
however fighting is not all in this game
a strength of an online game is in how
much you can immerse you into it and
make yourself an extension of your life
with its features and customization this
game does that well with so many
exploration and bonus activities
anything's possible and you can even
access the game's air system and make
your own house
life with a soulmate has never been this
awesome in video games
immerse yourself in the incredible world
of dragon raja and join the fun right
now
download links are available on the
video description and feel free to hop
into the game's many social media
accounts
for some amazing rewards
we'll be featuring one of the newest
shows out there now nobles if you
remember i listed right as one of the
most overpowered characters last year
you can go to the wiki to check out what
he's capable of with his list of
abilities but if you want something more
visual look no further than the final of
noblesse's anime adaptation where he
takes on clan leaders
it's rye versus three powerful opponents
and he still makes it look so easy it
never felt as if rye was in any position
to lose
tanking attacks here and there and just
stopping them with his open palm gave me
some mahoga flashbacks even together all
three of them are no match for rye
leading raskierra to finally step in who
finally gets a hit in on rye such is the
power of the nobles
the strongest among the nobles
one of the hallmark moments in mob
psycho comes in the form of mob
finally going beyond his limits we've
known mob to be capable of releasing his
psychic powers in many forms
but what if all the limiters go down
under extreme duress
mob's able to enter arguably his
strongest form the question mark
percentage mode
it's at this point where he loses
consciousness and just lets his powers
run wild
and it's not pretty especially if you're
hanazawa who learns his lesson the hard
way
just looking at the sheer destruction
mob is capable of without as much as
moving a finger is a sight to behold
imagine what he can do when he somehow
harnesses this form while conscious
if you were to ask me who my favorite
among the homunculus is i'd say king
bradley in a heartbeat given the company
he's with and the feats that the other
homunculi have to their name
that's no easy feat but let's just say
that this battle impressed me so much
granted i never thought that anyone here
would have posed a threat to bradley
even the named characters still it
doesn't make this one-man army any less
awesome take note that bradley at this
time is not even in his prime
imagine if he's younger at this time
precognition is probably one of the most
broken abilities in anime and giving it
to someone like bradley just feels over
the top don't you think when i think
about his eventual defeat
i still can't help but think he only
lost because the plot dictates that he
had to not to take anything away from
scar
but that's just how high bradley stock
had become when he eventually had to
bite the dust
parasite is one of my perennial
favorites and besides the themes i
particularly like how creative the fight
scenes are look when you've got a
protagonist with a transforming sentient
hand you have free reign to do lots of
things
not in this one fight though this is
just a simple showcase of sheer power
courtesy of the series last boss goto
people have commented on this scene and
compared it to a guy going back to a
starting area after reaching his level
cap and
i would agree with that the way he just
walks up to the yakuza and slaughters
them like it was nothing he dodges
everything perfectly and just creates a
sight for sadistic killers to behold or
for the sake
of limit testing man the yakuza really
can't get a break can they name
recognition and reputation just make
them perfect jobbers for anime
characters trying to make a point even
later on in the series against a world
that's increasingly adjusted to fighting
parasites gotho doesn't let
up i'm legitimately sure that without
our dynamic duo to stop him
the world is doomed at the hands of this
super villain
the poor yakuza get destroyed once again
in this next entry
this time courtesy of goemon
[Music]
you never had an idea that the lupone
series can be so violent
well this movie is not exactly
representative of the series as a whole
but it does have some moments that
showcase the grittiest sides of the gang
that you'd probably know more from their
comedic hijinks
here you have goemon just showing those
yakuza punks that they've messed up big
time they've come to pick a fight with
the wrong
guy they would quickly pay the price
with their limbs it doesn't matter that
goemon's not in his best state or that
he's outnumbered
numbers are nothing but stats for
someone of goemon's skill level
just watch you know as he ran through
the yakuza like they were nothing
here's to the most powerful of lupon's
gang by a long shot it's really good
that our protagonist got someone like
going on watching his back right
goemon also has some really insane
moments in the other parts of the lupon
series so you might want to check that
out in a previous video
[Music]
hmm
our next featured moment is in ari
furetha a show that i'd like to call
some twisted fusion between
shield hero and konosuba only much much
edgier so our protagonist is your
typical wimpy boy who gets betrayed
early on and falls to the symbolic
depths of hell fighting his way out of
it he becomes a monster of a man even
more so than the petty demons that he
gets tasked to face off in the show's
run
an army of 60 000 monsters would send
any village and kingdom
shaking to the core but for our
protagonist it's nothing short of easy
with his harem of various monster girls
hajime easily wipes the floor with the
entire army of hilarious cg
whatever you call those if the subtitle
from commonplace to the world's
strongest hasn't been driven home yet
maybe this moment will change your mind
the reason this isn't much higher is
because hajime did it with his harem
whereas later we have a person dealing
with a similarly large army
in just one super attack
here's an interesting addition why you
ask if you've noticed in this list
we generally have otherworldly powers on
display the characters featured so far
generally have some superhuman magical
abilities that allow them to do the
flexing so to speak but those things
don't come into play in sword of the
stranger
it makes it more awesome to see luo lang
just dispose of the entire team without
breaking a sweat
no precognition no super evil form no
alien abilities just pure swordsmanship
and
peak human performance luolang is a
monster beyond comprehension and his
introduction does a masterful job at
driving that point home
way to build up the final antagonist for
our hero to face in the climax
such an amazing build but the actual
fight is even better you can check it
out on my recent top sword fights list
which i'll be linking now
coming in in second place we have one of
the most overpowered anime protagonists
in eins eins has a lot of claims to fame
you don't get a horde of loyal followers
from the netherworld out of nowhere it's
not every day that you can command the
respect of the denizens of nazareth you
have to be an amazingly powerful
individual capable of just showcasing
your power and dominance in every corner
thankfully
eins has those qualities in spades don't
believe it well you can go and check out
the entire overlord series to just see
how powerful of a force irons is if you
want me to pick one specific moment
though
maybe this one will convince you which
anime character do you think
can kill 70 000 people in one fell swoop
in one super tier magic only irons there
are characters who've done this same one
man army on that scale heck we've had
one on this list but to do it in one
fell swoop
with one super spell sasuga in summer
indeed
who deserves the top spot besides the
king of heroes gilgamesh
gilgamesh being on this list is a
no-brainer he just oozes swagger and the
tendency to just flex his dominance over
others
among anime characters i just think that
gilgamesh especially his archer variant
in the mainline fade series is a top
contender for the title
of the most haughty and arrogant
character out there few characters can
compare to him or even come close
the truth is his arrogance is warranted
that's largely thanks to enuma elish
possibly the most powerful attack in
that line of fate he deploys it against
rider's own noble phantasm
some episodes back we already saw how
powerful riders noble phantasm was
how about gilgamesh pulling off an even
bigger flex by swinging his sword once
and shattering the entire field
destroying ryder's entire army
simply astounding for those who can't
get enough of enumer elysium fate zero
the much nicer caster gilgamesh also
whips the bad boy out in fake grand
order's babylonia adaptation
so you can look forward to that but this
moment from fate zero
is easily one of my favorite moments
from the entire fate franchise
so what do you think of this list do you
think that gilgamesh deserves the top
spot on this one
if not who do you think should have been
there instead be sure to leave your
thoughts in the comments section for
more discussion now if you enjoyed this
video
make sure to leave a like and hit that
subscribe button up there for more vini
tube goodness coming right up and you
don't want to miss any of them
trust me don't forget to check out the
sponsors of this video dragon roger the
link's in the description
with that i bid you farewell for now
stay strong
stay cool and stay awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you